President Trump is spending this Labor
Day weekend at the White House with
trade concerns the likely on his mind
trade talks between the u.s. and Canada
hit a snag on Friday after a Canadian
newspaper obtained off-the-record
remarks mr. Trump made to Bloomberg News
that raises doubts about the future of
the 25 year old North American freight
free trade agreement Paula Reid is at
the White House Paula tell us all about
it
well good morning Trump notified
Congress on Friday that he intends to
sign a renegotiated not to deal with
Mexico but the question now is whether
Canada will also be part of that new
deal and after a week of tense
negotiations Canada says they'll
continue to negotiate but as of right
now there is no deal Canada's ripping us
off dole world is ripping us off
President Trump spent the day in
Charlotte North Carolina Friday
spotlighting tensions with Canada as he
tries to fulfill a long-standing promise
to renegotiate NAFTA NAFTA was a
disaster a bilateral deal was reached
with Mexico on Monday but talks with
Canada have stalled over issues
including NAFTA's dispute resolution
system and access to Canada's dairy
market I said off the record
some things about Canada to make matters
worse the Toronto Star on Friday
published some harsh words the president
made during a bloomberg news interview
in which he said he would not compromise
with Canada on a trade deal but didn't
want his comments published because
quote it's going to be so insulting
they're not going to be able to make a
deal here's the good news at least
Canada knows where I stand because we
can't have these countries taken
advantage of the United States anymore
it's very simple the president's remarks
raised doubts about whether the US was
negotiating in good faith with Canada
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau asserted
he would not sign a deal if it hurt
Canada you will only sign a deal if it
is a good deal for Canada again no deal
is better than a bad deal for Canada and
for Canadians and that's exactly what we
are remaining Firma talks will resume
here in Washington on Wednesday but
congressional approval is needed for any
revised NAFTA deal and leaders of both
parties have said that both
Mexico and Canada must be part of any
revised agreement Alain Paula read at
the White House thank you